What concerns me at the moment is
something much more basic,
much more fundamental,
and much more closely related to the
core of Magna Carta.
What I,
what I said a little bit earlier was
that one of the fundamental points that
comes out of Magna Carta is the idea
that you have to have access to justice.
That if you can't enforce your rights in
a court,
you have no rights.
And in that sense,
David Wright,
that universal human rights are gfe if
they can't be enforced.
And that's why what interests me is not
so much universal human rights but
British civil liberties that can be
enforced in our courts.
And what concerns me at the moment is
that this government is conducting a
sustained an ideological attack on
access to court and it is parsing almost
without notice in the national media.
I want to give three examples of it.
First of all,
uh,
the so called reforms to legal aid.
Secondly,
the proposals made two weeks ago
massively to increase court fees which
are passed almost without comment.
And thirdly,
the new legislation which will restrict
access to judicial review.
Firstly,
in relation to legal aid,
as many of you will know,
uh,
two years ago,
the government,
uh,
removed legal aid for most forms of
civil litigation,
a whole areas where previously legal aid
had been available.
It was removed from including almost all
family law cases except where there's
recent evidence of domestic abuse.
This has resulted in a far greater
numbers of cases where people are
litigants in person cases taking much
longer and appalling situations arising
in court.
A situation a few weeks ago where a
father was seeking access to a child
where the mother said that he had
sexually abused the child where because
no legal aid was available,
the judge was contemplating a situation
where the father would have to cross
examine his own child on the truth of
the mother's allegation that he had
abused that child,
that that's an intolerable situation to
have in any court and it is the direct
result of government policy.
And the Lord Chancellor Christopher
grayling sent leading council into that
court to argue that it was the farthest
choice to be unrepresented because he
had the disposable income of 10,000
pounds a year.
I'm not making this up.
It happened.
So that's the first thing.
Legal Aid and the Public Accounts
Committee yesterday,
uh,
produced a report in which they pointed
out that the Ministry of Justice,
it introduced these reforms without
first taking the trouble to work out
whether the money they would save would
in fact be saved or whether they would
simply be not con costs in other
departments because of the physical and
mental harm done to people who would no
longer be able to get access to legal
advice.
And the comment of the Public Accounts
Committee at a,
a cross a party committee was that the
Ministry of Justice now has no idea
whether it's actually saved any money
from these reforms.